hello and welcome to the session of
timeseriesforecasting in this video we
are going to talk about what
timeseriesforecasting is and this is two
part series and in this first video we
will explain what is time series
analysis and in the second part we will
actually demonstrate it in our studio so
this is what we are going to cover in
this video first of all why time series
and then we'll talk about what exactly
is time series data and then what are
the components of a time series data
like for example the transition ality
and so on and then we will explain what
each of these components are you'll also
talk about when we should not use time
series analysis and we will then explain
what is stationary data at terms of time
series what is the significance of
stationary data and typically time
series data is not stationary so how to
make time series data stationary and
then we will take you through an example
of a car sales data and we will show you
how to solve the time series or how to
perform the time series analysis
manually without using a tool and then
we will do in the second part we will
actually use our and we will do the same
thing once again okay so without any
further delay let's get started and so
why exactly do we need to do time series
analysis typically we would like to
predict something in the future and it
could be stock prices it could be the
sales or anything that needs to be
predicted into the future that is when
we use time series analysis so it is as
the name suggests it is forecasting and
typically when we say predict it need
not be to the future in machine learning
in data analysis
you talk about predicting we are not
necessarily talking about the future but
in time series analysis we typically
predict the future so we have some past
data and we want to predict the future
that is when we perform time series
analysis so what are some of the
examples
it could be daily stock price the shares
as we talked about or it could be the
interest rates weekly interest rates or
sales figures of a company so these are
some of the examples where we use time
series data we have historical data
which is dependent on time and then
based on that we create a model to
predict the future so what exactly is
time series so time series data has time
as one of the components as the name
suggests so in this example let's say
this is the stock price data and one of
the company so there are two columns
here column B is price and column a is
basically that time information in this
case the time is a day so that primarily
the closing price of a particular stock
has been recorded on a daily basis so
this is a time series data and the time
interval is obviously at a time series
or time intervals can be daily weekly
hourly or even sometimes there is
something like a sensor data it could be
every few milliseconds or microseconds
as well so the size of the time
intervals can vary but they are fixed so
if I am saying that it is daily data
then the interval is fixed as daily if
I'm saying this data is an hourly data
then it is the data is captured every R
and so on so the time intervals are
fixed the interval itself you can decide
based on what kind of data we are
capturing so this is a graphical
representation the previous one here we
saw the table representation and this is
our plot the data so on the y axis is
let's say the price or the stock price
and x axis is the time so against time
if you plot it this is our time series
graph would look so as the name such as
versus time series data a time series
data is basically a sequence of data
that is recorded over a space
intervals of time and based on the past
values so if we want to do an analysis
of Time series past data we try to
forecast a future and again as the name
suggests it is time cities data which
means that it is time dependent so time
is one of the components of this data
time series data consists of primarily
four components one is the trend then we
have the seasonality then cyclicity and
then last but not least irregularity or
the random component sometimes is also
referred to as a random component so
let's see what each of these components
are so what is trend trend is overall
change or the pattern of the data which
means that the data may be let me just
pull up the pen and show you so let's
say you have a data set somewhat like
this a time series data set somewhat
like this all right
so what is the overall trend there is an
overall trend which is upward trend as
we call it here right so it is not like
it is continuously increasing there are
times when it is dipping then there are
times when it is increasing then it is
decreasing and so on but overall over a
period of time from the time we start
recording to the time we end there is a
trend right there is an upward trend in
this case so the trend need not always
be upwards there could be a downward
trend as well so for example here there
is a downward trend right so this is
basically what is a trend overall
whether the data is increasing or
decreasing
alright then we have the next component
which is seasonality what is seasonality
seasonality as the name suggests once
again changes over a period of time and
the periodic changes right so there is a
certain pattern let's take the sales of
warm clothes for example so if we plot
it along the months so let's say January
February March April May June July and
then let's say it goes up to December
okay so this is our December ID I will
just mark it as T and then you again
have Jan Feb March and then you get
another December ok and just for
simplicity let's mark this as December's
as the end of the year and then one more
December ok so what will happen when if
you are talking about warm clothes what
happens the sales of warm clothes will
increase probably around December when
it is cold and then they will come down
and then again around December again
they will increase and then the sales
will come down and then there will be
again an increase and then they will
come down and then again an increase and
then they will come let's say this is
the sales pattern so you see here there
is a trend as well there is an upward
trend right the sales are increasing
over let's say these are multiple years
this is for year one this is for year
two this is for year three and so on so
for multiple years overall the trend
there is an upward trend the sales are
increasing but it is not a continuous
increase right so there is a certain
pattern so what is happening what is
pattern every December the sales are
increasing or they are peaking for that
particular year and then there is a new
year again when December approaches the
sales are increasing again when December
approaches the sales are increasing and
so on and so forth so this is known as
seasonality so there is a certain
fluctuation which is which is periodic
in nature so this is known as
seasonality then cyclicity what is
cyclicity now cyclicity is somewhat
similar to seasonality but here the
duration between two cycles is much
longer so seasonality typically is
referred to as an annual kind of a
sequence like for example we saw here so
it is pretty much like every year in the
month of December the sales are
increasing
however cyclicity what happens is first
of all the duration is pretty much not
fixed at the duration or the gap length
of time between two cycles can be much
longer so this session is an example so
we had let's say recession in 2001 or
2002 perhaps and then we had one in 2008
and then we had probably in 2000 2012
and so on and so forth so it is not like
every year this happens probably so
there is usually when we say recession
there is a slump and then it recovers
and then there is a slump and then it
recovers and probably there is another
bigger slump and so on right so you see
here that this is similar to seasonality
but first of all this length is much
more than a year right that is number
one and it is not fixed as well it is
not like every four years or every six
years that duration is not fixed so the
duration can vary at the same time the
gap between two cycles is much longer
compared to seasonality all right so
then what is irregularity
irregularity is like the random
component of the time series data so
there is like you have thought which is
the trend which tells whether the
overall it is increasing or decreasing
then you have cyclicity and seasonality
which is like kind of a specific pattern
right then there is a cycling city which
is again a pattern but at much longer
intervals plus there is a random
component so which is not really which
cannot be accounted for very easily
right so there will be a random
component which can be really random as
the name suggests right so that is the
regularity component so these are the
various components of time series data
yes there are conditions where we cannot
use time series analysis right so is it
can we do time series analysis with any
kind of data no not really so what are
the situations where we are we cannot do
time series analysis so there will be
some data which is collected over a
period of time but it is really not
changing so it will not really not make
sense to perform any time series
analysis over it right for example like
this one so if we take X as the time and
Y is the value of whatever the output we
are talking about and if the Y value is
constant there is really no analysis
that you can do leave a long time series
analysis right so that is one another
possibility is yes there is change but
it is changing as for a very fixed
function like a sine wave or a cos wave
again time series analysis will not make
sense in this kind of a situation
because there is a definite pattern here
there is a definite function that the
data is following so it will not make
sense to do a time series analysis no
before performing any time series
analysis the data has to be stationary
and typically times it is data is not
stationary so in which case you need to
make the data stationary before we apply
any models like ARIMA model or any of
these right so what exactly is
stationary data and what is meant by
stationary data let us take a look first
of all what is non stationary data time
series data if you recall from one of my
earlier slides we said that time series
data has the following four components
the [ __ ] seasonality cyclicity and
random and a component or a regular
right so if these components are present
in time series data it is non-stationary
which means that typically these
components will be present therefore
most of the time a time series data that
is collected raw data is non-stationary
data so it has to be changed to
stationary data before we apply any of
these algorithms all right so a
non-stationary time series data would
look like this which means like for
example here there is an upward trend
the seasonality component is there and
also the random component and so on so
if the data is not stationary then the
time series forecasting will be affected
so you cannot really perform a time
series forecasting on a non stationary
data so how do we differentiate between
a stationary and a non stationary time
series data typically or technically one
is of course you can do it visually in
non stationary data the data will be
more flattish seasonality will of course
be there but the trend will not be there
so the data may if we plot that it may
appear somewhat like this right it's a
horizontal line along the horizontal
line you will see compared to the
original data which was there was an
upward trend so it was changing somewhat
like this right so this is non
stationary data and this is our
stationary data would look visually what
does this mean
technically this means that the
stationarity of the data depends on a
few things but the mean the variance and
the covariance so these are the three
components on which the stationarity of
the data depends so let's take a look at
what each of these are for stationary
data the mean should not be a function
of time which means that the mean should
pretty much remain constant over a
period of time right so there is there
shouldn't be any change so this is how
the stationary data would look and this
is a non stationary data would look I've
shown in the previous slide as well so
here the mean is increasing that means
there is an upward trend okay so that is
one part of it and then the variance of
the series should not be also a function
of time so the variance also should be
pretty much common
should be constant rather so this is a
if we visually we take a look this is
our time series stationaries data would
look when the variance is not changing
here the variance is changing therefore
this is non stationary and we cannot
apply type series forecasting on this
kind of data
similarly the covariance which is
basically of the ioud term and the I
plus Emmett term should not be a
function of time as well so covariance
is nothing but not only the variance at
Ayad term but the relation between the
variance at the I of the term and I plus
a meth or the I plus a net term so as
again once again visually this is how it
would look if the covariance is also
changing with respect to time so these
are the three all three components
should be pretty much constant and that
is when you have stationary data and in
order to perform time series analysis
the data should be stationary okay so
let's take a look at the concept of
moving average or the method of moving
average and let's see how it works we do
simple calculations so let's say this is
our sample data we have the data for
three months January February March the
sales in hundreds of thousands rather
not hundreds thousands of dollars is
given here and now we want to find a
moving average so do we find the moving
average we call it as moving average
three so moving average three is nothing
but you take three of the values or the
readings add them up and divide by three
basically the way we take a mean or
average of the three values so that is
as simple as that so that's the average
for so called so what is moving average
moving averages if you now have a series
of data you keep taking the three values
the next three values and then you take
the average of that and then the next
three values and so on and so forth so
that is how you take the moving average
so let's take a little more detailed
example of car sales so this is how we
have the car sales data for the entire
year let's say so rather for four years
so year one we have for each quarter
what a one two three four and then year
two quarter one two three four and so on
and so forth so this is how we have
sales data of
particular car let's say or our showroom
and we want to forecast for ef5 so we
have the data for four years we now want
to focus for the fifth year let's see
how it works first of all if we plot the
data as it has taken the raw data this
is how it would look and what do you
think it is is it stationary no right
because there is a trend upward trend so
this is not a stationary data so we we
need to later we will see how to make it
stationary but to start with just an
example we will not worry about it for
now we will just go ahead and manually
do the forecasting using what is known
as moving average method okay so we are
not applying any algorithm or anything
like that in the next video we will see
how to apply an algorithm how to make it
stationary and so on alright so here we
see that all the three or four
components that we talked about are
there there is a trend there is a
seasonality and then of course there is
some random component as well cyclicity
may not be it is possible that cyclicity
is not applicable in all the situations
for sales especially there may not be or
unless you're taking a sales for maybe
20 30 years cyclicity may not come into
place so we will just consider primarily
the trend seasonality and irregularity
right so random it is also known as
random irregularity right so we are
calling the random or a regularity
component so these are three main
components typically to this case so
when you talk about so this is the trend
component and we will see how to do
these calculations so let's take a look
we draw the table including the time
code we will add another column which is
the time code and it is the column and
we just number it like 1 2 3 4 up to 16
the rest of the data remains the same ok
so we will do the calculations now now
let us do the moving average
calculations or ma4 as we call it for
each year so we take all the four
quarters and we take an average of that
so
if we add up these four values and
divide by four you get the moving
average of three point four so we start
by putting the value here so that will
be for the third quarter let's say one
two three the third quarter then we will
go on to the next one so we take the
next four values as you see here and
take the average of that which is the
moving average for the next quarter and
so on and so forth now if we just do the
moving average it is not centered so
what we do is we basically add one more
column and we calculate the centered
moving average as shown here so here
what we do is we take the average of two
values and then just adding these values
here so for example the first value for
the third quarter is actually the
average of the third and the fourth
quarter so we have 3.5 now it gets
centered so similarly the next value
would be three point six plus three
point nine divided by two so which is
three point seven and so on and so forth
okay
so that is the centered moving average
this is done primarily to smoothen the
data so that there are not too many
rough edges so that is what we do here
so if we visualize this data now this is
how it looks right so if we take the
centered moving average as you can see
there is a gradual increase if this was
not the case if we had not centered it
the changes would have been much sharper
so that is the basically the smoothening
that we are talking about now let's go
and or do the forecast for the fifth
year so in order to do the forecast what
we will do is we will take the centered
moving average as our baseline and then
start doing a few more calculations that
are required in order to come up with a
prediction so what we are going to do is
we are going to use this multiplicity or
multiplicative model in this case and
this is how it it looks so we take the
plot of seasonality and the trend and
irregularity components and we just
multiplied
and in order to get that this product of
these two we have basically the actual
value divided by CMA YT value divided by
CMA will give you the predicted value of
YT is equal to the product of all three
components therefore st into YT is equal
to YT by CMA so this is like this is
equal to YT right so therefore if we
want st into YT the product of
seasonality and irregularity it is equal
to YT by CMA so that is how we will work
it out I also have an excel sheet of the
actual data so let me just pull that up
alright so this is how the data looks in
Excel as you can see here year 1/4 1 2 3
4 year to put a 1 2 3 4 and so on
and this is the sales data and then this
is the moving average as I mentioned
this is a we calculate and this is the
centered moving average so this is the
primary component that we will start
working with and then we will calculate
since we want the product of SC into YT
that is equal to YT by CMA so if you see
this values are nothing but the YT value
divided by ICMA so in this case it is 4
by 3 point 5 which is 1 point 1 4
similarly for point 5 by 3 point 7 1
point 2 2 and so on and so forth so we
take we have the product esteemed YT and
then the next step is to calculate the
average of respective quarter's so that
is what we are doing here average of
respective quarter's and then we need to
calculate the DC's analyzed values so in
order to get this is analyzed value we
need to divide YT by st that was
calculated so for example here it is 2.8
by 0.9 so we got the DC's analyzed value
here and then we get the trend and then
we get the predicted values so in order
to get the predicted value which is
basically we predict the values for
known values as well like for example
here one quarter one we know the value
but now that we have our model we
predict ourselves and see how close it
is so we predicted as two 0.89 whereas
the actual values
point eight then we have two point five
nine that you value is two point one and
so on just to see how our model works
and then continue that into the fifth
year because in fifth year we don't have
a reference value okay and if we plot
this we will come to know how well our
calculations are how well our manual
model in this case we did not really use
a model but we did on our own manually
so it will tell us the trend so for
example the predicted value is this gray
color here and you can see that it is
actually pretty much following the
actual value which is the blue color
right and the gray color is the
predicted value so that wherever we know
the values of two year four we can see
that our predicted values are following
or pretty much very close to the actual
values and then from here onwards when
the year five starts the blue color line
is not there because we don't have the
actual values only the predicted value
so we can see that since it was
following the trend pretty much for the
last four years we can safely assume
that it has understood the pattern and
it is predicting correctly for the next
one year the next four quarters right so
that is what we are doing here so these
four quarters we did not have actual
data but we have the predicted values so
let's go back and see how this is
working in this using the slides so this
is we already saw this part and I think
it was easier to see in the excel sheet
so we calculated the testee I to the
product of s T and I T using the formula
like here Y by Y T by C ma you got that
and then we got s T which is basically
YT so this is average of the first
quarter's for all the four years and
similarly this is the average of the
second quarter for all the four years
and so on so these values are repeating
they are calculated only once they get
repeated as you can see here and then we
get the DC's analyzed data and that is
basically YT by SD so we calculated s T
here and we have YT so YT by SD will
give you the disease analyze data and we
have got rid of the seasonal and zero
components so far now what we are left
with is the sign and before we start the
time series forecasting and serious
analysis as I mentioned earlier we need
to completely get rid of the non
stationary components so we are still
left with the trend component so now let
us also remove the trend component in
order to do that we have to find the or
we have to calculate the intercept and
slope of the data because that is
required to calculate the trend and how
are we going to do that we will actually
use what is known as regression to our
analytics tool that is available in
Excel so you remember we have our data
in excel so let me take you to the excel
and here we need to calculate the
intercept and the slope in order to do
that we have to use the regression
mechanism and in order to use the
regression mechanism we have to use the
analytics tool that comes with excel so
how do you activate this tool so this is
how you would need to activate the tool
from excel you need to go to options and
in options there will be a dense and
inheritance you will have analysis
toolpak and you select this and you just
say go to open up a box like this you
say analysis toolpak and you say okay
and now when you come back in to the
regular view of excel in the data tab
you will see data analysis activated so
you need to go to file options and
add-ins and then analysis toolpak
typically since I've already added it it
is coming at the top but it would come
under inactive application add-ins
so when you are doing it for the first
time so don't use VBA you just say
analysis toolpak there are two options
one with VB
I like this one and one without VBA so
just use the one without VBA and then
instead of just saying okay just take
care that you click on this go and not
just okay so you say go then we'll give
you these options only then you select
just the analysis toolpak and then you
say okay all right so and then when you
come back to the main view you click on
data okay so this is your normal home
view perhaps so you need to come to data
and here is where you will see data
analysis available to you and then if
you click on that there are a bunch of
possibilities what kind of data analysis
you want to do if there are options are
given right now we just want to do
regression because we want to find the
slope and the intercept so select
regression and you say okay and you will
get these options for input wide range
and input X range input Y range is the
value Y T so you just select this and
you can select up to here and press
ENTER and input X range you can what now
you start with the baseline or you can
also start with the D seasoned value so
you can just click on these and say okay
I have already calculated it so these
are the intercept and the coefficients
that we are getting for these values and
we will actually use that to calculate
our trend here Frank which is in the J
column so our trend is equal to
intercept plus slope into the time code
so the intercept is out here as we can
see in our slide as well so if you see
here this is our intercept and the lower
value is the slope we have calculated
here and it's shown in the slides as
well so intercept so the formula is
shown here so our trend is equal to
intercept plus slope into time curve
time code is nothing but this one T
column a what do they for okay so that's
how you calculate the shed
and that's how you use the data analysis
tool from Excel using these two we
calculate the predicted values and using
this formula which is basically turned
is equal to intercept plus slope into
timecode and then we can go and plot it
see how it is looking and therefore so
we see here that the predicted values
are pretty close to the actual values
and therefore we can safely assume that
our calculations which are like our
manual module is working and hence if we
go ahead and predict for the 50 or so
till 4 years we know the actual value as
well so we can compare our model as
performing and for the fifth year we
don't have reference values so we can
use our equations to calculate the
values or predict the values for the
fifth year and we can go ahead and
safely calculate those values and when
we plot for the fifth year as well the
predicted values we see that they are
pretty much they captured the pattern
and we can say if we assume that the
predictions are fairly accurate as we
can also see from the graph in the excel
sheet that we have already seen ok so
let's go and plot it so this is how the
plot looks this is the CMA or the
centered moving average the green color
and then the blue color is the actual
data red color is the predictive value
predicted by our handcrafted model okay
so remember we did not use any regular
forecasting model or any tool we have
done this manually and the actual tool
will be used in the next video this is
just to give you an idea about how
behind the scenes or under the hood how
focus ting works our time series
analysis how it is performed ok so it
looks like it has captured the trend
properly so up to here is the known the
difference we have reference and from
here onwards purely predicted and as I
mentioned earlier we can safely assume
that the values are accurate and
predicted properly for the 50 M now we
come to the summary so what have we seen
in this video we talked about time
series data why time series what exactly
is time series what are the components
of time series data that
seasonality cyclicity and irregularity
or random and then we talked about the
stationary time series data what exactly
is stationarity what are the components
of stationarity how about we visualize
stationary time series data and then we
use the moving average method to perform
forecasting of sales so this is pretty
much what we did is a manual method we
did not use any tool or any standard
model but this is just to understand how
time series analysis work and I hope you
enjoyed this video thank you very much
for joining the session and in the next
video we will talk about how to perform
this in using R and using a proper model
like a Rhema and hopefully you will
enjoy that as well so that's it for now
thank you very much if you have any
comments please put your comments down
below including your contact email if
you need any response we can respond to
you and hope to see you soon thank you
very much bye bye hi there if you liked
this video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here